[Music]
we know many formulae to calculate the
area of various geometric figures
which are very helpful in many real-life
applications
however these formulae are inadequate
for calculating the areas enclosed by
some curves
now in order to find such areas we need
the concept of
integral calculus we've already learned
how to calculate the integral of
a given function and briefly understood
how it could be used to find the
area under a simple curve
in application of integrals we are going
to understand this concept
in depth and find the area under simple
curves
the area between lines and arcs of
circles
parabolas and ellipses
so how do you calculate the area under a
simple curve
let's understand now consider a curve
given by
y equal to f of x we have to find the
area bounded by this curve
the x axis and the coordinates x equal
to a
and x equal to b now consider an
arbitrary vertical strip of height y and
width dx
and located at an arbitrary position
within the region
specified by some value of x between a
and b
so what will be the area of this strip
yes the area will be given by y times dx
and we will denote this area as d a
now we can divide the area under this
curve into a large number of such
thin strips each of these areas will be
called
elementary area now we can say that the
total area of the region
pqrsp is the addition of
all these elementary areas of thin
strips across the region
we can express this area as integration
of
d a from a to b on substituting d
a and y we get the integration as shown
similarly to find this area bounded by
the curve
x equal to g of y y axis
and the lines y equal to c and y equal
to d
we will consider a horizontal strip as
shown
hence this area is equal to the
integration from c to d
g of y d y now
if the curve under consideration is
below the x x-axis
and f of x is negative then the area
bounded by the curve
x-axis and the coordinates x equal to a
x equal to b will come out to be
negative
in such a case we will consider only the
numerical value of the area
so that's how we calculate the area
under a simple curve
in the next video we will solve an
example
based on this so see you there
[Music]